[Music]
there are still no leads as to the
identity of them the freaky folk hero
remains at large sir what did you see
last night I heard gunshot saw blood
handsome fellow had his arm tore off
like wet bread and the creature run off
into the nighte he looks like a
up hot
dog that part was very shocking to me
can we put that up anyone
that may have encountered the Strang
breaking news the group of armed extreme
the nasty Lads they've taken hostages at
a Mis meat lunch atorium downtown let's
go live We Are The Nasty Lads we
angry who the are
[Music]
you what the hell is that
the Toxic Avenger that's what the kids
are calling him I think it's
[Music]
swell